all right well welcome to my talk and
thanks for coming I hope you've enjoyed
the conference so far title of my talk
is algorithm intuition and let's just
jump into it so the first thing I want
to say is I'm not an expert I'm just a
dude this is a quote from Scott sure who
gave a talk in CPP con 2015 and he said
the following if you if you have an
answer for me because I'm not an expert
I'm just a dude if you have an answer
for me or if you have questions or
whatever else not only do you get to ask
your question or make your statement but
you also get chocolate so I stole the
quote and I also stole the the gimmick
so our volunteer here has chocolates
hopefully he can throw em out if you
guys have questions I'll try and throw
that thing to you just so that I don't
slow myself down trying to throw you
guys chocolates and then also I don't
have to be held guilty if he hit someone
in the head like Bryce did last night so
first things first a little bit about me
they should be like C++ facts about me
I love C++ I've been coding in C++ for 5
years there's an asterisk next to it
because for the first three I wasn't
using any algorithms or any data
structures from the STL libraries so
really everything I've learned has been
in the last two years
I love auto I'm definitely in the
triple-a camp almost always auto I
prefer East Coast and I've actually
hidden one Const West in all of my
slides two chocolates to the person who
can find it
I prefer East End functions so those of
you for not who are not familiar last
year Phil Nash gave a talk called or a
lightning talk home we have always been
at war with West kasnia and he was
arguing for trailing return types which
he termed East End functions and one of
the motivations he gave was that a
number of other languages do it so Swift
does it
Haskell does it and he also says that
mathematics notation commonly does it as
well I thought this was going to be
followed by a number of other slides
with other languages but it wasn't he
stopped it two languages so I'm gonna
enhance that rust has trailing return
type Python 3 with type annotations has
trailing return type go has trailing
return type Coghlan has trailing return
type if this isn't enough reasons to do
trailing return type and those of you
not familiar with the syntax its using
auto where you would typically put your
explicit return type and then trailing
return type at the end
so I'm definitely all for East End
functions it lets me write Haskell or
code C++ code that looks like Haskell
and also for those of you that who are
at C++ lightning talks last night
Chandler gave a lightning challenge
where he showed a minimal and clean api
for a map and if for those of you that
noticed he was using trailing return
types and it enabled the autos all
lining up and each of his four methods
lining up which in my opinion looks
really really nice so if you don't
believe me believe Chandler so back to
this I love algorithms especially STL
algorithms that's what we're gonna be
talking about today and I'm very
interested in programming languages in
general not just C++ although C++ is my
favorite at the moment and I like to
compete in competitive programming
contests so for those of you that listen
to CPP cast I was on episode 139 if you
want to hear more about competitive
coding and throughout this talk there's
gonna be three or four examples that are
pulled from these competitive
programming websites to motivate when
you should use different types of STL
algorithms so let's go back in time to
the beginning the year is 2013 the
conference is going native
the speaker is Shum parent and the talk
is c++ seasoning
that's a rotate so anyone in the room
with were they there for this talk no
hands who has seen this talk and knows
this quote that's surprising about half
the room so Sean gave this seminal talk
which is probably one of the most well
known C++ talks to date and he advocates
for algorithms
he says that's a rotate and he also says
it 24 more times
that's a rotate that's a rotate
that's a rotate that's rotate the rotate
rotate
no rotate because rotate rotate rotate
with rotate rotate rotate rotate rotate
rotate rotate and rotate rotate rotate
rotate rotate and a rotate rotate is a
very common operation that's a rotate
so clearly Shawn parent is a big fan of
rotate but also in the talk he mentions
a plethora of other algorithms that's a
find if find if the find if the lower
bound lower bound the lower bound
lower bound lower bounds lower bound and
lower bound lower bound lower bound it's
called stable partition stable partition
the stable partition stable partition
stable partitions stable partition
stable partition stable sort stable sort
does that and element and element and
element and element that's a rotate so
if you haven't seen this talk I
basically just summarized it but you
should go back and watch it it's a
fantastic talk but the most important
thing that he says and his whole talk is
the following in my opinion so you have
all these algorithms at your disposal
right learn them it's very important so
this was back in 2013 and this led to
what I would call a new age in C++ and
it's not a new age then at least a trend
of other speakers referring back to this
talk and there talks about how you
should know your algorithms the next is
CPP con 2016 when Marshall cloud gave a
talk about STL algorithms and how you
should use them and write your own one
of the things that various people have
talked about in the last several years
is using standard algorithms as in your
code
moving on to 2017 meeting C++ cake
Gregory simplicity is not just for
beginners to really write simple code
you need to know so much you need to
know the language you need to know the
whole language you need to know the
patterns and the idioms that we use you
need to know the libraries sean's
implementation of things where he says
this is obviously a rotate and all I
need to do is a partition followed by a
blah blah he ends up with like really
simple code because he knows the
algorithms that's not again a paradox or
an oddity that's actually the secret
sauce and then a few months later at ACC
you 2018 craig kate gregory again so I
mentioned the range tour you find a loop
that touches every element in the
collection
maybe I should change it to arranged for
or better still maybe I should go
looking algorithm if you've seen this
Shawn parent talk where he first starts
talking about algorithm and he says
hilariously this is obviously a rotate
and I was in a room full of really smart
people as we are today and I'm looking
around like they don't think it's
obvious today it's not just me is it it
was it was not obviously a rotate but
you want to get there you want to be
able to say hey this is obviously a
rotate and at the same conference ACC
you 2018 John Baqarah gave a very
popular talk by the title 105 STL
algorithms in an hour so there's a fact
that's been popularized across the C++
community over the past couple years is
that we need to know all the SCO
algorithms you've made before we seem
that talk from one parent a couple years
ago who transform a big chunk of code
into a very small and expressive piece
of code just by choosing the algorithms
correctly and finally a few months later
at code dive Odin Holmes says hey that's
an accumulate I know what that does who
knows what that does
good crowd most of you learn your
algorithms learn your patterns and then
a quote from a CPP cast episode which
gave me the title of my talk what you
know that it's pretty obvious we can use
upper bound for this and you know
doesn't in a single line and we all have
to start going through this that you
know in I thinking about five years C++
developers who don't recognize
opportunities for rotate and upper bound
and and you know really all of algorithm
are going to be kind of in the dust
compared to the people who spot
something in the real world and just as
you can say that would be a good use of
a linked list we don't have that
intuition about algorithms yet anybody
know who that was
okay Gregory episode 30 I definitely go
listen to it we don't have that
intuition about algorithms yet and we
need to when I heard this line I knew
that was what I was going to call this
talk that was about a year ago so thank
you Kate I'm sorry for stealing your
words but it's an awesome title talk so
we're gonna bring it full circle back to
Sean parent who gave a talk at Pacific
C++ called generic programming where he
said the following
one of the main algorithms inside of STL
is is stable sort and it's an in situ
stable sort and not that long before the
STL was published in Knuth art of
computer programming an in situ stable
sort that was solvable in polynomial
exhale it'll solution in there for
stable sort that builds it up out of all
the other algorithms all the algorithms
within the STL fit together like puzzle
pieces right I saw this and I thought
who writes code like this okay right I
mean keep in mind here I'm working with
a bunch of phenomenal engineers right
great people these are some of the top
people in the industry and I've never
seen somebody who writes code like this
okay this is not like the code that Alex
published in in his paper five years
before right he's clearly grown and had
some time to think about it so it's just
this phenomenal piece of work and for me
it was like like I want to write code
like that how do I write code like that
it's this phenomenal piece of work and
for me it was like I want to write code
like that this is someone who inspires
me talking about Alex Stepanov someone
who inspires him for me this is awesome
just listening to all these talks and
then hearing Sean say this
few months ago it's what motivated this
talk or contributed to motivating this
talk so I want to develop algorithm
tuition
I want to write phenomenal code and I
want to write beautiful code the last
quote is actually from one of my
favorite television shows black mirror
the procedural algorithm is it's amazing
it's just some beautiful code thank you
beautiful code beautiful code one more
time beautiful code we live in a golden
age of television we're a software
developer can watch a television show of
other software developers telling them
how beautiful their code is this is like
my career goal
I just want my colleagues to come up to
me and say that is some beautiful code
yeah anyways so that's what motivated
this talk and the goal for today for you
is hopefully to get you excited about
algorithms hopefully I've already done
that a little bit to learn a new
algorithm I know everyone in this room
is an expert so potentially you won't
learn a new algorithm but maybe you'll
start to develop some algorithm
intuition about how you can make use of
some of these algorithms so we're gonna
start with a warm-up question not that
any of the experts in this room you
don't want my question but maybe some of
the people watching this on YouTube
later will and so the question is given
an array of integers find the difference
between the minimum and the maximum so
we're gonna go through sort of the worst
you know response to this question to
the best response and this isn't opposed
to be a trick question this isn't
supposed to show how clever you are to
solve it it's just supposed to go
through show a number of different ways
and how we can use sort of more modern
C++ features to get to the best solution
so we're gonna whip through this because
I've got other content to get to so the
first solution quadratic and time
complexity it's basically just setting a
local variable answer to the minimum
possible value and insurer can assume
and then in the nested for loop two
indexes I and J and just resetting that
variable to be the maximum difference
that you see so far note that on the
first line we're using C++ Seventeen's
seat add class template argument
deduction but who likes this solution
for the record no hands went up so we
can slightly improve this solution
without reducing the time complex
by using a C++ 11 feature anybody know
what it is range for so doesn't make it
look that much better but it is an
improvement so just note whenever you're
accessing every single element in a
range and you don't need the index use a
range based for loop moving on to the
next solution slightly better time
complexity and log and the solution here
is to sort the elements and then
subtract the last one from the first one
because we know in a sorted list the
last one's gonna be the largest and the
first one's gonna be the smallest it's
not that good though because at the end
were dereferencing decremented iterator
which is returned to us by end and then
do you referencing begin so we can
slightly improve this by dereferencing
our begin which is a reverse iterator
that gives us basically the first
element at the end of the list but
there's a way that we can improve this
even more without having to dereference
does anybody know someone said it throw
my chocolate and also throw Bennett
chocolate so yes not only should you
know your algorithms you should know the
methods on your data structures next
solution so now we're at optimal time
complexity this is linear we basically
have two locals a and B that are going
to be our minimum maximum range based
for loop going through resetting them
however we can use two STL algorithms to
solve this min element and max element
so some would argue this is less
efficient because now we have two for
loops so we're going to be indexed or
incrementing our index more than we need
to but this is just to illustrate that
we have two algorithms that we can use
to solve this so who knows an algorithm
better than these two that we can use to
solve this problem min max element all
right just throw everyone a chocolate so
yes oh yes in C++ 20 will have our range
based versions of these algorithms so we
don't have to pass the iterators yeah
just throw out throw one to everyone I
got a second bag here that I can give to
you so as everyone mentioned a min max
element is an algorithm that we can use
that returns a pair of both the minimum
and the maximum from our list so here
we're storing a P which is a pair and
then just subtracting P dot first from P
dot second after dereference in them
because they're iterators anyone know a
c++ 17 structure bindings don't want to
Vittorio thank you
so structure bindings probably one of my
favorite C++ 17 features I know it's
just syntax sugar but for me it's
amazing it enables you to name and D
structure the first and second from your
pair and so then we can just dereference
b - dereference a and with c++ 20 will
have the range based version of this
algorithm and we won't need to pass the
iterators so this makes me extremely
happy on the first line we're using c++
17 c tab the second second line c++ 17
structure bindings we're making use of
what I thought was a more esoteric
algorithm min max element but apparently
everyone in the room knows it and then
we're just returning the difference so
not a very complicated example but it
illustrates a number of different
features you can use and I think this
code is beautiful there are a few things
wrong Oh Ben right right it does it yes
it does in fewer comparisons and it's
one loop so it is more efficient same
time complexity as the previous solution
but it is actually a more efficient
solution so there's a few things wrong
with the solution that I'm sure a few of
you thinking it's not that beautiful so
I just want to point them out and may
make a point that this is just slide
where so a slab where disclaimer the
number one mistake that I'm making here
is I'm not using stood name space I
don't use stood name space on most of my
slides unless if I'm referring to a
function object in one of the function
headers just because I think it makes it
look cleaner solve terrible function
name a and B terrible variable names
name your functions better name your
variables better in production code and
sort of failing solid so the D in solid
obviously everyone knows is dependency
inversion typically this refers more to
classes but the fact that I'm hard
coding my vector into my function
shouldn't be doing that it should be a
generic function that I can call over
and over again but the point is if
you're noticing small things like this
in my code know that I'm aware of them
too and that this is just slide where
code alright a small digression we're
going to take a look at one of the
previous examples which is this one here
and there's a small improvement we can
make to this and when I initially wrote
these slides I didn't have this in any
of my slides and it was only because of
listening to a podcast that I ended up
discovering this so the point that I'm
gonna make here is that everyone should
go read this book who has read this book
raising hands
one person so everyone should go read it
it's Edlund edited by kevin Henny and 97
things every programmer should know it's
just a collection of points one of the
points is continuous learning and in one
of those sub points it says follow the
advice of the pragmatic programmers and
if we go there take a look at what it
says in Chapter one basically says the
same thing but it's learn at least one
new language every year different
languages solve the same problems in
different ways by learning several
different approaches you can help
broaden your thinking and I can't agree
with this more I've been learning
Haskell recently it's changing the way
that I write C++ code how does this get
us back to this well when I was
listening to this podcast functional
geekery amazing podcast for those of you
interested in functional programming
they made a comment about Ruby and also
JavaScript but mainly the point was
about Ruby and it's that they have this
syntax of an exclamation mark that
notates a mutating method so you'll have
a piece of code like this s is equal to
string and then you call strip which is
a mutating method and that's what the
exclamation mark denotes in notes that
you're modifying the underlying data
structure and another digression inside
this digression is that exclamation
marks mean different things in different
languages so in Ruby it's mutating
method rust it's a macro not C style
Lisp style
D it's a template type similar to the
angle brackets in C++ and Haskell I mean
strictness so don't think that
exclamation mark means this in every
language the point is every language has
their own opinion and of the Internet to
agression him back to the first
digression so how can we modify min max
elements that isn't mutating the
underlying data structure but
technically it could be what change can
we make does anybody know Vittorio gets
another chocolate the C so I've seen in
many presentations that talk about
algorithms and not most of them most of
them don't have this it's a small change
that I think shouldn't be excluded from
slide where that makes a huge difference
if you like functional programming this
is much more functional and if you're
gonna take one thing away from my talk
this is like number four out of ten so I
think this is an important point know
that when you're right using algorithms
you should think am i mutating if I'm
not use the cost versus of these so
that's the end of that digression these
are some different solutions just
because it's fun python is always the
most terse Java don't really like Java
and then Haskell so moving on to the
bulk of the content of my talk we're
gonna start by stealing some content
from Jonathan Becker's talk the 105 STL
algorithms so you know gonna plug him a
bit go watch this talk because I'm about
to steal his content he gave it both at
ACC you and it's TPP Khan and he's got a
great blog flu in C++ which I'm sure
many of you are familiar with so he
gives he shows this map called the world
of C++ STL algorithms and on it he sort
of combines all the algorithms into
different regions based on sort of
properties so the first comment I'm
gonna make on this map is that there are
not 100 at five algorithms on this map
there's 71 because I counted and part of
this is because of the fact that in the
bottom left corner he's got this secret
room section and the secret runes are
basically the prefixes and the suffixes
that you can append to algorithms to get
slightly different ones so we heard Sean
parents say earlier stable partitions
stable sort that's using the stable
prefix added to sort and partition which
are also algorithms so he only shows the
partition and the sort algorithms and he
sort of says you can combine the secret
runes to get more so if we add those we
get 32 algorithms that aren't shown on
the map which gives us 103 still too
sharp of 105 so I went and checked and
these are the eight that he left out and
of course I been when he tweeted at him
Jonathan what are the two that get us to
105 and he responded find if not is
indeed counted as it's in the slides not
the others you're mentioning because it
doesn't take they don't take a beginning
end so that still only gets us to 104 I
don't think we'll ever know what the
missing 150 algorithm is but at least we
know that the motivation so yeah I find
if not as the one that was included the
rest of these don't take a begin and end
so yeah we'll never know about the point
to know is that what motivated the
algorithms going on the slide are the
ones that take iterators the second
point that I want to make is that
Jonathan left off I think a crucial
Islander aisle on this map so it's a
secret aisle so maybe that's why he left
it off but I decided to add it and it's
the law style of operators just down at
the bottom here and so what these are is
these are function objects that the
function header provides us with when I
started starting or starting to use
algorithms more I was constantly writing
lambdas that just took two parameters a
and B and then just added them or
multiplied them
we already have these they're in the
function header if you find yourself
writing simple lambdas over and over
again that just sort of wrap and
operator use the function objects that
are in the function header and obviously
or not obviously they're called operator
wrap wrappers for that fact because
basically they're just wrapping an
operator so on to our algorithms it
isn't explicitly stated in his talk but
there are three different headers that
are included on that map algorithm
numeric and memory and this is the
breakdown across the different C++
versions so pre C++ 11 C++ 11 in C++ 17
so in total there's actually 111 104
plus the 7 that he left off and anyone
know the one algorithm that we delete in
C++ 17 Ben gets another chocolate better
watch out you need to go on a diet Ben
oh he doesn't want the chocolate anyway
so we're gonna focus mostly on the
numeric algorithms algorithms in this
talk so does anyone know one of the four
original numeric algorithms Ben iota
that's actually incorrect
Bryce accumulate throw my chocolate
that's one all right
okay four chocolates - Bryce yeah yeah
partial sum those are the four four
chocolates - Bryce and we'll ask Ben oh
you're talking about so the for the UH
the people online Ben was talking about
a PL not C++ that's why he got confused
a PL for those of you that know stands
for a programming language and it's got
a beautiful syntax anyone know the C++
11 algorithm Ben iota so these are them
in blue are the pre C++ 11 and yellow is
the ones that C++ 11 and in green are
the C++ 17 so we're quickly gonna look
at iota there's not much algorithm
intuition to be developed here you just
need to know about it it basically given
a range generates a sequence if you give
it forward iterators it goes you know
one to ten you get reverse iterator as
it goes backwards I have more to say
about this but I don't have time in this
talk maybe I'll give it in the lightning
talk in the future if you want go and
you know search on Twitter for iota
shaming there was a Twitter storm that
happened back in January but I'm not
going to talk more about it happen
here but it is entertaining so iota
check next hour than we're algorithm
we're going to talk about is accumulate
so this is another slide stolen from
Jonathan's talks and it in this he shows
basically visually what the default
operations of each of these algorithms
are so first we're gonna look at
accumulate you can see here each of
these pluses so the default binary
operation that accumulate comes with is
plus and we're gonna sort of burn to
this next part because I'm sure or who's
familiar with a key might raise the
hands actually less than I would expect
I'd say 80 percent of the room put up
their hand so accumulate you pass it to
iterators and initial value and it's
just gonna sum the elements it's gonna
add them so we're gonna get six one plus
two plus three
this is the exact same as this this is
the default binary operation or function
object that accumulate comes with but we
can override it so we can pass it
multiplies we want to change the
identity value because if we have an
identity value of zero you're gonna end
up with zero but this isn't really that
nice because for me accumulate has the
semantic value of sort of adding things
you know you accumulate wealth you
accumulate a number of other things and
it's sort of adding this stuff up you're
not necessarily multiplicatively you
know performing an operation on it so
it's not the best name enter
c++ Seventeen's reduce basically the
same algorithm there are a few
differences but for this purposes for
this example they do the same thing so
the first line and note that you can
actually drop your identity value if
you're using the default binary
operation plus and it'll just default it
to zero so that's sort of nice the
second line where we're setting why does
the exact same thing and then Zed is the
same as what we saw before so the first
time I heard about the reduce and fold
operation was when I was listening to
this podcast lambda cast and he and on
the podcast they mention that it's
called the number of different things in
a number of different languages so fold
reduce accumulate as what we know is
what we know it in C++ eleven aggragate
I believe is what c-sharp calls it
compress and inject and so the point to
know is that this reduced fold operation
is a super super common operation that
is known as a different number of
different things in different languages
and the second thing to note is that
they have an episode called morphisms
where they talk a little bit about
category theory and this falls into the
category of cata morphism which is
basically this idea of having a list or
a foldable and shipping it down into one
element now note that you can have a
lists that shoots down to one list so it
doesn't necessarily need to be a single
value but it's this idea of taking a
structure and then folding it down into
a single value doesn't need to be the
same value that the data structure could
contain Dan it initially and we'll see
that in a second so taking a look at
rust there's it's called fold and it's
very similar to accumulate and reduce it
takes a range and initial value D is has
fold and reduce and note that they
actually have two different versions of
each of these functions they have one
argument and a two argument the two
argument is similar to the C++ 'iz and
rusts the one argument uses the initial
value as the first element so it doesn't
take an initial value it just uses the
first element of the range as the
initial value interesting to note and we
need to start to pay attention to this
reduces our everywhere we can implement
many of the stl algorithms with a reduce
stood count counting the number of ones
and our vector V taking a look at a
sample implementation this is not you
know library quality but you can do this
and it works you know namespace template
takes two iterators and your value that
you want to count captures the value in
the capture list two parameters a is
your accumulator which keeps track of
like the running count and B is your
current element and you just return a
plus B equal to V I know there's an
implicit cast there just ignore it but
when B is equal to your value you end up
adding one to sort of the running count
taking a look at another example any of
returns true when the predicate that you
pass it returns true for any of the
elements in your data structure so in
this case we have a predicate in the
form of a lambda which returns true if
your elements equal to three sample
imitation of this namespace template
takes two iterators a predicate P
captures the predicate when you make a
call to reduce initializing the value
that you're gonna return to false
because if you have any of a list that's
empty it's gonna be false and then in
your lambda body returning a logical or
the predicate evaluates waiting B and
this is gonna do exactly what any up
does so the point is is that reduces or
everywhere this is not an exhaustive
list but I just went through all of
these could be implemented using a fold
operation now note that the way that we
implement
implemented and reduce they sort of
restrict the types that you can return
so you couldn't actually implement all
of these with C++ is reduce or
accumulate the
though that these are all cat amorphic
algorithms these all fall into the
cattle morphism category of category
theory so just try and pay attention and
you'll start to notice then I actually
as an exercise for a token in 2016
implemented a bunch of algorithms as
accumulate as a fold as Conesus of the
90 that were in Super Plus 1477 would
double as a fold
so 77 of 90 algorithms that bending
implemented could be implemented with
the fold so clearly I did not
exhaustively go through here but there's
probably a lot more so the point is
folds and reducer everywhere once you
start to notice them so there's a final
note I want to make about reduce and
that's that they are parallel algorithms
they come with the ability to provide an
execution policy which will then turn
your algorithm into a parallel algorithm
so I'm not gonna talk about it here
because I don't have time this is a
high-level talk but if you're interested
in this there's a great article by Simon
brand who works for Microsoft called
stood accumulate versus reduced the
links there he talks about the three
different policies SEC power and part
unseat and Brice also has a great talk
that you can go and watch so these are
resources if you want to know more and
note that accumulate and reduced they're
not identical they are sort of reduces
the the newer version of accumulate but
there are differences in them so
accumulates done reduces done ayat is
done we're now going to look at a
problem and it's gonna be solvable with
one of the three remaining presea plus
plus algorithms and I've taken this from
a website and modify the problem a
little bit see if you can you know see
the difference so john cal biz going to
give michael and odin each one coin john
has n coins with different values john
wants the absolute difference between
the value of the coins to be minimized
so michael and odin don't fight with
each other given an array of coin values
help John find this minimum now this is
you know may seem like a simple problem
but it's actually very important because
we know that if Michael or Odin get a
value a coin that's much greater than
the other this is what's going to end up
happening they're going to end up crying
so we really want to minimize this as
much as possible so here are a couple
examples if we have the coin values 1 4
& 2 we
want to give the coin values one and two
because then the difference will be
minimize to one and if we have the coin
values one three and three this is the
best case because that Mykel and odin
end up with coin values that are the
same so the difference will be zero so
does anyone know which of the three
remaining presea plus plus eleven
algorithms we can use to help solve this
problem adjacent difference so here we
have a function min value that accepts a
vector of integer coins and then on the
second line we're declaring a vector of
integers diff we're gonna shorten this
coins will be C def will be D just so
it's easier to read and on the first
line we sort and then what we're gonna
do is we're gonna call adjacent
difference which is going to calculate
the differences between the adjacent
elements and that's a property of a
sorted list that we know that the
closest elements are always next to each
other so if we just take the differences
and then on the last time line take the
minimum element from that list of
differences we're going to end up with
the minimum difference and note that we
have to take the minimum difference from
the second element in our vector D
because the way that adjacent difference
works is it the first element is always
going to be the initial element
subtracted or minus zero so you're
basically end up with the first element
which isn't a valid difference that we
want to consider price so thank you
Bryce I'll pay you later what's wrong
with the second line so implicit in
Bryce's comment so Bryce's comment was
can we do the last two lines sort of in
one sort of transform reduce operation
and that's gonna foreshadow a slide
later and the point is that we don't
need to do a linear space allocation
with vector D if we look at the type
signature of the function declaration
we're going from a list of integers to a
single integer why does that require
allocating extra space we should just be
able to get to our answer and so a way
to do that
not as elegantly probably as Bryce would
like but we'll get to that later is by
thinking cat amorphic Lee and using a
reduce do not write code like this this
is bad code and I'm pretty sure this
code is actually broken but this is just
supposed to illustrate a point that you
can solve this function or this problem
without allocating linear space
so we do our sort and we make a call to
reduce initialize it to the maximum
value that an inter can assume and then
in the capture list we initialize a
value called previous because we need to
keep track of the previous element and
we initialize that to the first element
then we have to have a modifying
algorithm or modifying lambda because
we're gonna be mutating that previous
and then we calculate our difference B
minus previous reset previous so that we
can keep track of it for the next
iteration and then just return the
minimum of our current minimum that we
found so far a and the difference that
we just calculated so like I said this
is not good code you should be writing
but it illustrates a point vitorio know
so that is part so this won't work I
said it's broken and yes yes so
accumulate is guaranteed to go from left
to right and that is what's talked about
in the resources that I provided so
there is a slight difference you
shouldn't be writing code like this
where your lambdas are carrying state
because then it's not guaranteed to work
in a basic example like this if you run
this code it actually probably will work
but as soon as you're doing stuff in
production it won't so we're gonna come
back to that problem later but for now
we're gonna say adjacent difference
check so next problem is also gonna be
solvable by one of the two remaining c++
pre c++ eleven algorithms so you're
given a length L of n posters and the
wall Heights W at which they will be
hung they are hung at the 75% mark of
the poster given Chandler has height H
how tall a ladder does he need so what
this looks like is we're given some
inputs and this represents three posters
that are hanging on a wall the one of
the points that we're given is the top
of the poster the next list is going to
represent the length of the poster and
so we're given the height of Chandler
who's right there but unfortunately he
can't reach the posters so we're gonna
need to give him a ladder and this
problem is asking us to find the height
of the ladder which is gonna be here so
basically the problem reduces down to
what's the maximum point on each of
these posters that's represented by
where the green meets the orange that is
the 75% mark of the poster so the way we
can solve this is with a simple
mathematical formula which basically
type takes W the top of the poster
subtracts the length divided by four
because we're hanging it at the 75% mark
and then ceilings that because the
problem states we can't pin it's at or
hanging it at a non integer value and
then
acting Chandler's height from it note
that if we do integer division with the
L divided by four we can actually get
rid of the ceiling because when you
subtract something divided by four which
we know is going to round down and
combine that it's basically going to
have the effect of a ceiling so what
does this solution look like this is how
I initially solved it P stands for point
the point at which we're going to hang
it and unfortunately I need the indexes
in order to look into two different data
structures the list of top the list W
and the list L so the top of the posters
and the length of the posters if we only
need one of these we could just do this
in an algorithm or some sort of range
base for loop but because I need to look
into both of these data structures I'm
not able to make use of those so we look
at Java same thing you know except we're
not using bracket operators we're using
get and note that I consider this like
an anti-pattern then Dean actually
talked about this a little bit in his
talk last year easy to use hard to
misuse whenever you see initializing
that variable and then either modifying
it in sort of if statements you can use
an immediately invoked lambda the same
thing here goes for when you're
initializing a variable and then
mutating it in a for loop especially if
it's you know P equals for every
iteration this is an anti-pattern this
is solvable some other way that's much
cleaner so let's go to python and this
made me extremely sad so python has a
function called zip which basically
takes two lists and gives you a list of
tuples with each of the elements from
those lists paired together and then you
can combine that with destructuring
similar to structure bindings in c++ 17
where it basically D structures each
element out of your list of tuples now
so this gives us a generator expression
which we then can apply sort of a
transform operation you're a minus B
into the division for and then just fold
it down using the max and you can do
that all in one line so this is
beautiful
having this zip to combine two lists
together and then at two at a time
stripping out those elements and
performing a transform on it it's just
amazing and it made me really really sad
that c++ didn't have this and then Simon
Brand tweeted so I'm not going to go
through this the important part is the
following
C++ code with the zip in it
and so I tweeted it Simon oh my goodness
rain just comes with zip please tell me
this is coming in C++ 20 he said they
are in ranges v3 but I don't think
they're coming in 20 and I think the
update is that it's still up in the air
but it doesn't look like it's gonna get
in because they don't have enough people
working on it and I responded this makes
me so incredibly happy I was literally
just googling to C++ 17 C++ 20 have zip
and Python you're able to solve this so
much more beautifully and then 13 days
later this was December 3rd 2018 13 days
letter I had just the most amazing
weekend when I discovered inner product
which is a function that you should
reach for when you want sip it enables
you to look into two data structures at
a time and then perform a transform
operation binary operation and a full
binary operation so basically what this
is doing we're passing it beginning and
of W beginning of L we don't need to
give it the end because we already have
the length from W and so it's just going
to match the length that we're going
from begin to N and W we initialize it
and then our first lambda is our full
binary operation our second lambda is
our transform binary operation so a and
B here are from W and L there are two
elements from W and L at the same time
we perform our transformation a minus B
divided by four and then in our first
lambda we perform our fold
so this was just fantastic and funnily
enough there's some comments to be made
about this and I believe the next thing
I'm gonna show is some slides and a clip
from mat gall boat stock so for a moment
I'm gonna plug Hannah's meet-up which is
amazing so she has a C++ meetup in
Prague she not only posts all the videos
question now write quote the comment was
Vittorio does not find the previous
slide very intuitive Thank You Vittorio
you agree with Matt you'll see in a sec
and anyway so Honda's meetup not only
they post all the talks to youtube they
livestream them go follow her on Twitter
go subscribe to this YouTube channel
it's a this talk is one of the best C++
talks I've seen and I don't think I've
seen it anywhere else so yeah
kudos to have asked for you know
investing in this kind of meet up and
flying people out her
the lineup is amazing I think you just
tweeted your next speaker is gonna be
Eric Kneedler individual behind ranges
works for Facebook anyways number of
slides from Matt go bolts Matt gobbles
talk I'm not gonna go through them in
detail but it's very similar to what I
did with the interview warm-up question
oh you give him a gig if you guys are
paying attention give him a chocolate
but this isn't my code then that holy
smokes we know who's paying attention
anyway so he points out that pre C++ 11
this is disgusting vector double colon
colon Const iterator and now we have
Auto so that's fantastic but we also
have range based for loop and we also
can solve this with an algorithm with a
function object but now in C++ 11 we
have lambda so we can solve it like this
and then someone told him he actually
didn't have this initially in his slides
but he added it then you can solve this
with inner product where you pass so so
this I didn't even mention sorry this
problem is RMS root mean squared you're
squaring all of the elements in your
vector of doubles and then square
rooting the sum of those squares and
someone pointed out that you can solve
this with an inner product just by
passing the same range twice which means
you're going to be multiplying the
elements together and then adding them
up so the default binary operations that
you get with inner product are
multiplies for the transform and plus
for the reduce but then Matt gobo says
the following about this and so this is
a one line for the entire function that
we had before and I am NOT a functional
person so I don't personally prefer this
style I think it's more intention
revealing to actually just see the code
written out but I know many people that
who I've worked with who RFP people and
they're like yeah this makes more sense
to me and with the ranges that are
coming in C++ 20 alone of this stuff
will look even more easy to use so two
important points there one Matt agrees
with Vittorio and says that he doesn't
find this intuitive the second point is
that this is gonna get better with C++
20 ranges and that's going to be a
recurring theme so we come back to this
solution yep okay so there's a comment
that says if we do it with numerix it
can overflow
so yes I guess that's a good point but
that's a detail and right
don't miss the forest for the trees so
it's a good point pay attention to make
sure that you're not overflowing so the
point here though is that inner product
is not in tension reviewing its inner
product does not have anything to do
with what we're doing right here not the
best name transform reduce C++ 17
algorithm this is my favorite algorithm
by far some people would still argue
that it's not intuitive but this is so
much better than inner product in that
it is explicitly saying what we're doing
and it's generic transform reduce so
let's quickly take a look
transform reduced we're given two
vectors one two three four V two three
four for you and the default operations
that come with this are plus and
multiply so we're gonna get 1 times 2
plus 2 times 3 plus 3 times 4 is gonna
be 20 but the point about this is that
you can overload your binary operations
do whatever you want
and transform reduce is still a good
name for what you're doing because it's
it's a generic term for the fact that
we're transforming and we're reducing I
had one problem with it though why not
call it zip reduce like technically
there's a zip implicitly happening that
we're not we're not calling out but we
decide to call it transform cuz there is
a transform as well there's both a zip a
transform and reduce but I thought I
thought why you know in a product it
would have been so much better if the
upgraded version was called zip reduce
because I think the zip is more
important than the transform we don't
need to zip so we go to CP dereference
one sec michael basically the third
overload of this function only takes one
range and it takes a binary operation
for our fold and a unary operation for
our transform so you don't need to zip
and that's why transform reduce is
actually a much better name because one
of the overloads you're not zipping so
what taking a look of what this looks
like if you have a vector V one two
three there's two different ways to code
this and I actually don't have a formed
opinion on which way is better so here
we're basically summing the squared
numbers on the first line we're just
using reduce and in the lambda body we
do both the reduce and the transform the
B times B is the square and the plus 2 a
is the reduce
the second line we use transform reduce
with the non zipping version where we
explicitly separate the fold and the
transform so I would say whenever you're
you're folding your transform operations
get complicated you definitely want to
reach for transform reduce where you're
not zipping but in a simple example like
this I'm not actually sure which one's
better Michael you had a question
earlier that's a good point so so
Michael pointed out that he thinks is a
zip is sort of a packaging mechanism and
less of something that is it going to be
in an algorithm is that a good
paraphrase it's just a packaging and
then one operation and it ignores the
more important second operation okay
yeah so that's a good point and the
Michael points out that basically to
ignore one of the main two operations
happening in the algorithm probably
wouldn't be a good idea but it doesn't
matter because I agree with transform
reduce anymore all right I would do I
agree the transform reduce is the name
that this should have been but yes
acknowledging both operations is
important being battement transform
reduce is analogous with regular
transform though right because regular
transform we often the way we often use
it is as a unary functional yes but
there's a binary version of it yes it's
a fantastic point and we're gonna see
more hopefully if I get to it later but
that is a fantastic point that transform
reduce is like an enhanced or is just
functionality added to what we had in
transform which is a pre C++ 11
algorithm so if you want to talk to if
you have a formed opinion or like use
cases on which of these of these do you
think is better come find me afterwards
I'd love to hear your opinions but yeah
I don't have my mind made up about which
is better here so let's revisit our
previous problem the one where we were
finding the minimum difference between
coin values so the last time we looked
at it we looked at it with a reduce
which I said don't code like this and
Bryce alluded to the solution that we're
about to see and that's the following a
transform reduce where the first range
is the elements 0 to n minus 1 and the
second range is the elements 1 to N so
basically even though we're looking at
two different ranges they're both on the
same range we're just looking at
different sub ranges and that gives
us adjacent elements and then we can
just take the absolute difference of the
two different the two elements that are
adjacent to each other and then the fold
operation that we're doing is just
taking the minimum anybody know a way we
can improve this code though uh yes
that's an improvement give me chocolate
it's not the one I was thinking of
anyone else oh yeah that actually I give
him a chocolate but that's true
so that actually didn't that didn't work
cuz you can't use a reverse iterator
this is not just returning a value it's
returning an iterator that we needs to
be paired is the same so a good point
there was one in the back yes so that is
half of the point so the point of the
back was we don't need the absolute a
minus B we always know B is greater than
a because it's sorted so we could just
go B minus a but even more so we can
just switch the ranges well so go ahead
okay yes so Bandhan vitorio and then
Oded at the back also get chocolates
come and grab them later so the first
point was yes we don't need the absolute
value the second point we don't even
need the lambda we can just make of use
of stood - and we just need to reverse
the ranges so that was something I
didn't notice until months after I wrote
this but definitely me so this is the
way to solve it in Haskell
I don't like formatting code like this
you can compose it like this and this is
something that she's going to come up is
that in functional languages we don't
need to have one algorithm and it does
it all we can just compose smaller
algorithms so the way this works is it
just sorts one two four takes the
differences and then takes the minimum
so digression how much time do I have 37
minutes yeah we can watch it so let's
see a simple example we want to count
all the repeated occurrences consecutive
repeats of a character in usually in
functional languages you will do this by
pairing using the original array then
use its tail and then you have pairs of
letters for each pair you just calculate
check are they the same are they not the
same etc and then you just need to sum
everything conceptually these are three
completely different operations
barring read another collection then
iterating through all the elements and
doing the transform or as usually is
called in Haskell map and then you do
the accumulation to count how many
characters should be repeated in C++ we
have a completely obvious algorithm for
doing this which is called completely as
expected in a product so when you see
the name inner product this is
immediately what what comes to your mind
counting the adjacent the currencies of
a character right and product it's just
that so the inner product is a really
cool example that you should never use
obviously because this is not this
wouldn't fit feel rather quote now we do
have the transform reduce which sounds
much nicer and transform videos could be
fitted for this but the problem is a
little bit bigger than than just the
name we have three different operations
but since we have the iterators and
iterators are not easily composable this
couldn't have been just two different
algorithms this needs to be a single
algorithm that is a composition of all
the previous three so what can be done
to remedy this so this was a talk
clearly given from Ivan couch it's at
ACC 2019 I actually watched this talk
just like a week ago
and added this to my slides and I
couldn't believe what I was seeing I
thought I was so clever that I'd come up
with this sort of you know 0 to n minus
1 1 to n pairing using a transform with
adjacent elements and then he does the
exact same thing and then gives a talk
about it like two months before me so he
gets credit but he says three really
really important things so you know I
couldn't believe it when I saw this but
we need to unpack what he said so one
was that you know in a product is a
really cool example that you should
never use and if you watch my lightning
talk on Monday you know I already
mentioned that the second thing he said
was transform reduce sounds much nicer
but that's not the whole problem and and
the most important point that he makes
and I'm not gonna read this whole thing
with a summary is that there's three
operations happening here a zip a
transform and a reduce but because
iterators aren't composable we need to
pack those all into one algorithm
whereas we want to be able to just have
three smaller functions that we can
compose together which is what we saw in
the haskell solution so this is gonna be
a theme we've sort of heard a little bit
of this before when when Matt Gobbo
mentioned that you know C++ 20 ranges
were coming and if you want to hear what
Ivan has to say about what he thinks is
a solution to this go watch this talk so
this is just a wait you can solve this
using the same adjacent difference
algorithm we saw earlier and count if so
like I said if you saw my lightning talk
we sort of show this earlier but note
that we're making a call to one
algorithm a Jason difference and then
another algorithm count if whereas in a
functional language we can just compose
these that's what the dot there on the
last line is a composition operator
they're two separate algorithms that we
can call it once and they get lazily
evaluated it's much nicer and this is
what ends up happening we've got our
values it takes the differences between
them and then just returns the number of
times we see zero which means the
adjacent elements are equal so that's
the end of that digression
so transform reduce it's amazing learn
to love it's my favorite algorithm and
this is incorrect so reduced should be
here but transform reduce should be up
with inner product so that was a mistake
on John slides fantastic talk but
definitely that was an oversight and you
should pay attention to
once again the diagram of the plus being
the fold operation and the multiplies
being the transform operation that inner
product and transform reduce come with
so now we've covered accumulate adjacent
difference in a product iota transform
reduce and reduce and that leaves us
with one pre C++ 11 algorithm partial
sum so partial sum comes up way more
than you'd think and I'm not going to go
through all the use cases I'm just gonna
go through a couple and probably what's
my favorite problem in this whole talk
the first is range sum when you have to
range when you have to sum multiple
ranges if you're gonna do this once it's
just linear time you just loop from one
to whatever call it accumulate you're
done but if you've got multiple queries
where you need to get the sum of
different ranges you can use partial sum
and I'll show how in a sec use a binary
search I'm not going to show an example
with this but there are many
applications where you can use partial
sum to construct a data structure of the
partial sums and then you use binary
search to change a quadratic algorithm
into an N log n algorithm so maybe in
the future I'll talk about that and then
you can use lambdas to overload the
default plus binary operation that the
algorithm comes with so first I've been
talking about it but I haven't even said
what it does if you're not familiar
partial sum basically is a transform
that calculates the partial sums up to
the given index that you're looking at
so given a vector of just all ones the
first element in your
vector u which we're gonna be generating
using partial sum is gonna be one then
the second is going to be the sum of the
first two elements which is two the
third is going to be the sum of the
first three which is three so once so
far for the second example we have one
two three four and you can see here we
get one for the first element 1 plus 2
for the second element 1 plus 2 plus 3
for the third element some 1 and so
forth
does everyone get that I'm seeing nods
so the first example when you have
multiple queries where you need to sum
multiple ranges or a single range so you
can imagine we've got this map of you
know key value double key value which
are both integers and queries we've got
our vector V which is 1 to 100 and we
need to sum up the ranges so we want to
know what's the sum from this index to
that index and like I said if you just
need to do this once you just call and
accumulate you're done if you need to do
it multiple times though you can call
partial sum populate you with the
partial sums and then loop through and
you can get the sum of that sub range by
just subtracting the value at B from the
value at a or the value at a from the
value of B does that make sense
I see nods and this is a trick that I
learned from competitive programming
that happens very commonly whenever you
have some problem where it has multiple
queries where you you have to sum these
ranges you just you can make a most
people don't call partial sum they just
write it with a hand roll for loop but
you can use partial sum and then do
these queries so that's a neat trick
moving on to our next problem which is
probably my favorite problem in this
whole talk and I'm not going to say when
or with which company but I actually got
this exact problem in an interview once
and I did not solve it as elegantly as I
did now I wish I had over but yeah given
n non-negative integers representing an
elevation map where the width of each
bar is 1 compute how much water is able
it is able to trap after raining so you
can imagine if this is sort of like your
mountainous range and then it rains how
much water is this range mean to trap so
we're gonna simplify this problem and
look at an easier version which involves
the maximum being at the end so you
don't have sort of a mountain you just
have like an incline and so the way
you're gonna solve this is you are going
to basically do a single pass from left
to right keep track of what your maximum
that you've seen so far is
and then at each step add to some
running sum the difference between the
current height and the maximum you've
seen so far so it ends up looking like
this for your first one your maximum is
going to be two two minus two is zero
you don't add anything from the next
step your height is one and so you
subtract one from two which gives us 1
so then we know that at this point we've
got one I guess unit of rain two minus
two is zero we reset our maximum that
we've seen so far to four at this point
and then on our next step four minus two
is two
that gets us these two next step four
minus three is one that gets as this
unit of rain does that make sense to
everyone so it's a single pass keeping
track of the maximum height of your
range that you've seen so far and then
you just do a difference of the current
height that you're at whenever you're at
the maximum you just get zero and
whenever there's a difference you're
gonna add that to your running sum so
what does this look like imperative leaf
without using any algorithms it's pretty
straightforward
you've got your vector you've got a
variable M for the max that you've seen
so far that you just initialize to be
the first element of your range then
you've got your answer which is going to
be the total amount of rain that you
were able to capture and then you have
your range base for loop at each step
you reset your maximum and then you also
do a plus equals to the answer which is
your plus equaling the maximum you've
seen so far plus the current element or
the height that you're looking at and at
the end you just return your answer does
that make sense to everyone I'm seeing
nods as a question at the back yeah
there's a problem with those so so yes
this is simplified version of the
problem you missed when I said we're
guaranteed that the maximum is the last
element but you're correct yes if this
was the original problem it wouldn't
account for the right side of our our
mountainous range but this is how we
would solve this imperative Lee so how
could we solve this with algorithms
partial sum over loading the binary
operation with max so we're no longer
taking the partial sum at each point I
we're taking the max that we've seen so
far at each index I and so that this
partial sum applied to you basically
gives us the white and blue combined so
we're gonna get 2 2 to 4 4 4 5 5 5 and 7
yeah
my intuition for this is is like a
reduce the remembers the previous things
is that correct yes it could be this
this this simple version of this problem
could be solved with just to reduce as
well but we're trying to highlight
partial son right now
yep oh great question I tried to so the
question to be repeated is how come I
didn't use stood max why do I have this
in a lambda that wraps it and that's
because in C++ elite this actually
worked pre C++ 11 and then in C++ 11 we
added an overload to max that takes an
initializer list so it can no longer
figure out which max it wants so we need
to wrap it but I actually have a file on
my github called useful function objects
where I provide this to you as a
function object that you need so I'm
gonna show that on the next slide but
there's an but so the point to make for
the last call transform reduce we're
then taking the difference of the white
and blue and the white which gives us
the blue is basically what we're doing
on the last line here so there's another
improvement that we can make on top of
you know getting a nicer function for
the max does anybody see what it was it
was similar to what we had before on the
last line we know that the B is always
going to be greater than the a so once
again we can switch this to stood - and
over here you see that this is UFO max
that's what I referred to as my useful
function objects because yeah it's it's
it's irritating what's getting mixed up
here it's irritating to see this one
like you should just be able to call max
yeah this this looks pretty clean in my
opinion if only we had a stood max that
we could use unfortunately we can't
but once again partial sum partial sum
like explicitly in the name is that
we're we're calculating partial sums
it's not partial max it's partial sum
not the best name introduced C++ 17s
inclusive scam inclusive scan is your
revamped partial sum and you might be
thinking I see a few squints in the
crowd is that the best name this is it's
taken from other languages I'm pretty
sure in Haskell you have a scan function
that does exactly this a couple
different versions so
scan idea is is it's common in other
languages so yes inclusive scan but much
better name let's go back to the
original problem now we were solving an
easier version how do we so so this is
what Oded made a point at the back is
that this doesn't work for this side we
can't just do a single pass from left to
right because at this point max max max
it's not gonna work so how can we modify
the solution that we just looked at to
solve the full problem so let's take a
look at our initial code the first thing
we need to do is to identify what the
maximum so we've got the at maximum now
the second thing we need to do is we
want to stop our first inclusive scan
not at the end of our range but at the
maximum let's just replace that next
after the it because we want to include
the the maximum although I'm pretty sure
actually at the maximum you just gonna
end up subtracting 0 so you don't need
the next and so what's the second thing
we need to do bending with the solution
inclusive scan with reverse iterators to
the maximum and you see this little
reverse here where does that come from
it's a templatized type alias so what's
the main difference between type def and
using is that using is template able
what this is using is readable okay to
difference is using is readable and you
can also template ties using so this is
actually this is C++ 17 it makes use of
C++ 17 seat add class template argument
deduction if you're using C++ 14 with
the reverse right here you need to use a
deco type on the iterator to get the
type but yeah C++ 17 so part him okay
and so there's a comment from the front
that said there's that make reverse
function so maybe you don't even need to
do this template izing using and then
casting but yeah didn't have to make too
many changes and then we solved the
problem then
oh great point great point so Ben yeah
Ben Dean with a fantastic comment that
there is from inclusive scan it returns
an iterator that we could use in the
second one and we wouldn't actually have
to use reverse it array I you would
still need to reverse it but right you'd
still you'd still have to reverse it but
the point is well so you could make use
of the iterator that is returned from
the first call to inclusive scan is the
point yeah so yeah this is probably one
of my favorite pieces of sort of
competitive coding algorithm it makes
use of three different algorithms max
element inclusive scan and transform
reduce and it makes use of all these
function objects plus - UFO Max and it's
super clean and if you look at the
imperative version of this you're
basically adding a second for loop to
what we have before looping backwards
that has another comment maybe
definitely have to go right to left yeah
I think that's right
so the Ben's comment or you you had the
mic but that basically we don't need as
much memory you'd still need to know
like where the max is like as it might
not be at the center but the point is
but you need you need to know the the
distance yeah exactly the bigger half is
the point and so the point is that you
don't need as much memory like this is
suboptimal in terms of the extra memory
that we've allocated and that whatever
is the larger half where the maximum
occurs you could only allocate that much
and just sort of reuse yep so yes
they're technically I'm sure as a
solution where we allocate zero memory
but then it wouldn't be as nice for a
demonstrating inclusive scan so but it
but it's a good point yeah possible as
possible so yeah to paraphrase you know
there there could be a couple other ways
that are more efficient to solve this so
we've covered accumulated Jason
difference exclusive scan inclusive scan
inter product I guess technically we
didn't include exclusive scan but
basically the difference is is you
provide an initial value and it doesn't
take the initial about the initial
element is the initial value and then it
excludes the current ailment that you're
looking at but it's basically just a
variation of inclusive scan so if you
understand inclusive scan it's just one
step to include understanding exclusive
scan inner product iota partial sum
reduce and transform reduce we're gonna
ignore the other two and we're going to
move on to probably what is the most
important part of this talk and it's the
algorithm and tuition table yeah
[Music]
damnit I made this slide I made these
slides last night see I apologize
hopefully it's gonna be spelled wrong on
the next slide too so here's a table
help most of the algorithms that we've
looked at so far
iota it really shouldn't be there but I
just felt bad lifting leave me a note
poor iota and these are three properties
for all of these algorithms so the first
property is the number of indexes we're
viewing at a time note that it's not the
number of elements so if we're looking
at transform that takes two ranges I
consider that one index because it's a
single index across two different ranges
two indexes means we're looking at you
know index I and index i plus 1 the
second is an accumulator so accumulator
is what typically we call the first
parameter in a binary operation that
we're passing to a folder reduce
operation it's the value that's being
dragged along and you know plus equal to
or whatever the operation that you're
doing that's what they refer to it in
functional programming you don't hear it
as often in C++ but the first parameter
of a binary operation that you you know
pass to a fold or a reduce is referred
to as the accumulator parameter and okay
so apparently I have not read the
wording that's remember I said of just
dude not an expert but it is actually
what's used in the wording and then the
second is whether the algorithm is a
reduce or a transform note this is just
sort of a category I hope I'm not
reinventing category theory here but the
idea is that you know accumulate inner
product reduce transform reduced these
are all produce algorithms whereas
partial sum exclusive scan inclusive
scan these are all transforming or
mapping they're creating a new range
this is a way to think about it so three
properties and you can see three
properties they're each binary we should
have a algorithms to the three we've
only got a few here so adjacent
difference just for example you know it
takes a look at two indexes it doesn't
have an accumulator it's only looking at
each index at a time and then at the end
it's generating sort of a range so it's
transforming it's not reducing so the
first thing we're going to do is we're
going to add adjacent reduce we've seen
this example a couple times where we're
basically taking a look at the adjacent
elements and we're performing both a
transform and reduce
this is just basically a specialized
form of transform reduce but it's common
enough that I want to throw it up here
and note that the asterisk next to this
one means that we can look at multiple
ranges at a time so even though there's
a one here the one could apply to one
range or it could apply to two ranges
not so much for inner product but for
transform reduce we do have that ability
tutorial what what does
well first adjacent reduces a
specialization of transform reduce now
reduce because reduce can only look at
one range transform reduce can look at
two ranges so basically adjacent reduce
it is just a transform reduce time using
inner product here but it could hurt him
nope yes on a single range but you're
passing it to 0 to n minus one and the
one to end so that's what this F so
maybe I went over that a bit quickly the
F and then decrementing the exactly
exactly so it's just I wish I wish we
had this in the algorithm because it
seems to come up so often and and as
mentioned I was talking with being the
other night and then he pointed out the
yeah this is a common pattern in
functional programming it's called zip
tail you zip with the tail which is the
one to n of your range and then you
perform operations on on the pairs so
another spelling mistake solving a
problem with the algorithm intuition
table so here's our problem we're not
gonna read it it boils down to this give
it a strings of 1 give it a string of
ones and zeros return true if the
longest contiguous substring of equal
elements is greater than or equal to
seven so two examples the first example
we have two zeros one to zeros one
there's no substring that has equal
elements greater than or equal to seven
but on the second one we've got a bunch
of zeros in a row that has more than
seven so how would we go about solving
this problem imperative Lee this is what
it looks like so max players we're gonna
shorten 2mp current players what yeah
that's it
I've done I'm too focused but yes that
is the West Const Victoria I'm being
both get another chocolate yeah I'll
just give this you guys have been
answering so many you can have this
afterwards
but yeah we're gonna shorten max players
and current players to MP and CP in a
second and basically what we're doing
here is max players is going to be our
final result and current players is the
current number of equal elements that
we've seen in a row and then we go
through our index for loop starting at
one we're checking are the two elements
equal to each other so si is an equal to
si minus one if so do an increment on
our current players otherwise reset it
back to one and then once we've done
that we just set our max players equal
to the maximum that we've seen so far
and our current ooh that's a bug right
there that temp should be current
players it's the same thing a pre
increment or post increment is the same
as a plus one okay yeah so the point is
that I shouldn't be using a pre
increment or a post ringman i should
just be doing plus one right right I
actually and I changed this line I used
to have it differently using the ternary
operator to mimic something but I didn't
like it so I changed it last night
anyways
it's a good point and then at the end
you just return is our max player is
greater than seven so this is imperative
li how you'd solve it so if we go to our
algorithm intuition table how do we
choose our algorithm well first how many
indexes do we need we're looking at two
elements that are side-by-side so that's
two indexes do we need an accumulator
well yes because we need to calculate
what's the current number of equal
elements that we've seen in a row and at
the end of the day what are we returning
a single element or regenerating a range
and it's that we're doing a reduce so we
choose adjacent reduce so here's our
solution and this makes use of a
functional programming trick where when
you need both sort of a temporary and
then a maximum of the temporaries that
you saw you use a pair so we're calling
a jason reduce initializing our pair to
b11 and then our pair is our accumulator
and are the first line of our lambda
body where d structuring our pair to be
the max player in the
player so like I said before max players
MP current players CP so this is a
little bit easier to read so the max
player is the first element in our pair
that we're using as our accumulator and
the second is our current player and
we're basically doing the same thing
then
so our second is going to be an equal
which we get by using the equal to
function object so that's going to be
our transform that we perform first on
the adjacent pairs of elements in this
adjacent reduce algorithm so it's gonna
look at the adjacent elements look are
they equal and transform those into a
boolean and then we're gonna pass that
with our accumulator to our fold lambda
that then basically does what the
imperative solution does so if the
elements were equal we do a pre
increment as oded pointed out that we
should be doing plus 1 there otherwise
resetting to 1 and then returning a make
pair of the maximum question yes that's
a great point so this algorithm does not
short-circuit it could be performed more
optimally by returning out yes so so
this is an adjacent reduce that is a
specialization of transform reduce that
has that takes two binary operations the
fold which is this big lambda and then
the transform which is the stood equal
to so that the transform on the last
line is applied first and takes our
adjacent elements and converts them to a
vector boolean's question following up
on the comment from the back about
short-circuiting so I don't see a way
you could do this wait I'm not going
like at the reduce you're showing here
you can't so is this like a win for
imperative programming maybe but yes
it's just it's a point to be aware of
that sometimes you want short circuiting
algorithms and we're gonna see in a
second that there are short-circuiting
algorithms built into the sto algorithm
librarian another question
No yeah so the question was can you use
a break inside an algorithm the answer
is no so pardon yeah been Dean's comment
you could throw an exception probably
not what you want to do yeah so so the
point is yes you can create a
short-circuiting version of this that'll
be more efficient the point here is that
functionally we can solve this way
better we have a number different
algorithms that we can compose and what
this is doing is group is a function
that's a little hard to see up there but
it basically it groups a list into sub
lists or in this case a string into sub
strings a list of substrings of equal
elements and then we can just take the
length of those sub strings - 1 2 - 1 or
2 1 2 1 and then take the maximum of
those and then just check is that
greater than or equal to 7 so functional
programming for the win
so back to this table let's extend it we
have three properties that are binary
and we're only looking at how many
different versions so the first two are
one yes reduce one yes transformer the
next - so that's only two out of eight
then we have to know transform which is
another one and - yes reduce so we've
only got four to eight algorithms here
when we should be able to complete this
to have a set of eight so anybody know
what algorithm matches this looks at two
at a time doesn't have an accumulator
and reduces no we want to replace the
happy face with an algorithm
it's a great question that's why there's
an asterisk next to reduce because it's
it is a reduce but it's a
short-circuiting reduce which could be
implemented in terms of reduced which
doesn't short-circuit but the way that
it's implemented it short circuits
pardon who said it that Jason find so
there's a reason that I have an asterisk
you can see it next to the reduce is
it's reduce asterisks it's it's a
short-circuiting reduce you could
implement adjacent fine in terms of
reduce but it's really not you've got a
while loop as soon as as soon as your
predicate returns true which in this
case we're trying to find two equal
adjacent elements you're done and it
returns it but it's still you can think
of it as a reduce next up one asterisks
no transform this one should be easy we
said transform so this is a well named
function unlike some of the others which
we'll get to in a sec what about this
one whoa one no and reduce Oded said at
the back that's fine once again with an
asterisk because it's short circuits
it's not actually gonna fold over the
whole data structure it's gonna return
as soon as the predicate that you pass
it returns true who's seen this example
before Wow
two people two people and it's amazing
that I happen to be talking to been one
of the individuals that raised his hand
in the crowd about this example so you
can generate a Fibonacci sequence with
transform that basically passes for the
two ranges one that starts at the
beginning and one that starts at the
second element and then outputs to the
third element and then the binary
operation that you're performing is just
a plus which you've initialized your
vector using this constructor here all
to one so initially your vector is all
ones and so when you add one one
together you get two and then for your
next iteration you have one two and you
get three and now you're generating
Fibonacci and when I talk to Ben and
this is amazing so this is why C++ now
is is so awesome is that I didn't have
the next slide in my slide deck
initially
he pointed out that you can solve this
with a more specialized version of
transform which I'm pretty sure is what
Odette was gonna sing nope
yes so you'll be fun so the question was
will this will this perform an order
because otherwise you're gonna end up
overriding yourself yes it will but the
point that been made is he and he
actually brought this up I I can't
remember what I was talking about and
then been Oh have you seen the example
where you can use adjacent difference to
calculate Fibonacci because adjacent
difference is basically just a
specialized version of transform which
upsets me why did they call it adjacent
difference the default operation that
adjacent difference comes with is minus
but here we're overloading it to plus or
replacing it with plus and now it has
nothing to do with difference adjacent
difference should be called adjacent
transform and that's how you should
think of it and it really it really
upsets me because it's such a great
algorithm it's a specialization of
transform when you can when you pass two
ranges to transform but you're never
gonna think of that because it's called
adjacent difference you're only going to
think about it when you want to take the
difference between two elements aha
thank you the question was what would
your default be the next slide talks
about the default operations that come
with your algorithms I would argue none
of these algorithms should come with
default operations that's the way
functional programming works you're
given generic algorithms that don't come
with default binary operations and you
specify them that's why in the in the
Haskell solution we saw a map adjacent
that is basically just adjacent
transform in Haskell they don't have
transform they have map they're the
exact same thing and their algorithm is
called map adjacent are should be called
adjacent transform and Ben has a comment
like in Haskell it's its default
operation is what we call it make pair
right so it's actually zip right well so
yes zip tail the PTO to sequences making
pairs of the boys yeah so maybe there
could be a zip in there so the comment
was yeah basically that maybe there
should be zip in the name but the point
is regardless whether you're putting zip
in or whether you're putting transform
in adjacent difference is not what this
algorithm should be named and probably
if I had to guess make an educated guess
about back in the 90s when Stepanov was
creating these or whoever ended up
initially creating this algorithm it was
that the use case was commonly like that
way more common that you needed to
subtract adjacent elements than you
needed to add them and so they said ah
well we want to make it easier for
people to use these algorithms so let's
let's give it a default and then if they
want to they can override it but we want
to make this more approachable and that
is something about functional
programming there is a little bit of
more of a learning curve in terms of
higher order functions and you know
passing binary operations and whatnot
but I would argue that you know adjacent
difference shouldn't have the name price
yes but that's it exactly
so Bryce's comment was that we only have
overloads for one range and two ranges
what about three four five six yeah so
hopefully we C++ 20 been so annoying
thing and it doesn't matter in practice
and I can't remember now which of the
algorithm specify it but some of them
and probably transform is one of them
specify that you can't change your input
ranges and if you're zipping with your
tail like in the fibonacci version then
you're writing to your if it were you're
writing to your input range I think yeah
so technically undefined behavior
because you're violating the functions
conditions but it's annoying yeah that's
a good point
anyways I've got it says four minutes
left I might go a little bit over but
I've only got like 18 slides left so the
next
I'm gonna make is the following oh wait
I'm not gonna make a point so quickly
I'm gonna go through this we're missing
one so if you look at it we've got seven
out of eight now but we're missing - yes
transform and so I figured okay I'll
quickly go implement this sad face
because we don't have it and I'll call
it adjacent inclusive scan because you
know why not that's basically what we're
doing we're just doing an inclusive scam
but looking at two elements at a time so
that's why we've got the two indexes and
I went and looked at the Microsoft's
because that's what I have visual studio
in my computer I quickly put it together
you see previous elements accumulator
we're not gonna really look at it and
this is a use case of how you would do
it basically this is doing partial sum
but only including elements that are
equal to each other adjacent lis equal
to each other otherwise you're not
including it in the partial sum but does
anybody know what's odd about this or
what I just did accidentally that's a
good point but not not what I'm looking
for the point here is that where do you
have this these were the two that I
ignored I realized this two days ago so
yeah well done to the people that behind
these adding these algorithms they
completed the set of the three different
properties transform exclusive scan and
transform exclusive inclusive scan so
where I had adjacent inclusive scan is
what we wanted with transform inclusive
scan so yeah pay attention to the
default operations the next points is
that is just to echo what Ivan kucik
said and Matt goblet said these it's not
composable how many of you know find if
there's an algorithm it's basically find
with a filter but what if we wanted to
add if to all of these well now we've
got four properties to to the 416 and
you can think of those runes that were
on Jonathan Picard slides is all
different sort of you know there's
underscore N and the point here is that
these algorithms are not composable and
I think C++ 20 ranges is really gonna
help with that
so one last problem you might have
noticed at the beginning of my talk
my title slide I had the following who
knows what this is from I like what this
represents
Scrabble it's a board game anyone not
familiar with Scrabble
okay so Scrabble is basically a word
game where you've got this board that
has double letters triple letters triple
words and then each of your tiles has a
value and you spell words and sort of a
crossword like fashion and try to score
points by superimposing the value of
your letters on this board so you spell
the word algorithm you place it here you
need to calculate the score what
algorithm is this or transform reduce
they're everywhere once you start to
learn your algorithms you find them
everywhere
technically you might be thinking oh
well you avoided the fact that you could
have a double word and the double word
changes the algorithm yes yes I know but
it supposed to be an illustrative
example of just these algorithms are
everywhere like I never used to see them
and now that I know them I see reduces
everywhere and I see transform reduces
everywhere that's the point I want to
make is that Scrabble it's like one of
my favorite board games and now when I
think it I'm sort of doing a transform
reducer and before we conclude there's a
bunch of small points I want to make it
says I got 10 seconds although we
started late a bunch of other
conferences every single one of these
conferences has a YouTube channel that
posts all their talks so thank you to
both John and Danny and the video crew
this is my first conference that I've
attended but I've been able to watch
just hundreds hundreds of videos online
because they all post them online also
podcasts there's two c++ podcasts I
think most people are familiar Jason and
Rob are for CPP caste and John Calvin
Iser of this conference and film Asher
for CPP chat and there's also two
functional program or podcasts that I
highly recommend
I think I'll raise the hands who's read
these Oh actually less than I think 80%
so this is more for the YouTube audience
but if you're gonna be you know C++ pro
should definitely go read Scott Myers
books subscribe to me on youtube I have
a channel that solves you know
competitive programming channels and you
know I post things to Twitter as well if
you're interested in any of the slides
from my talks with the videos for my
talk
go to this link here every single code
slide has a different file with the
right extension so it's syntax
highlighted correctly this isn't updated
because I was changing slides up until
yesterday but by the end of today it'll
all be updated and to conclude
algorithms are awesome and they're fun
especially transform reduce but we
covered a number of other ones know the
default operations of that the
algorithms come with but then leverage
them with function objects and lambdas
and know that C++ 20 ranges are coming
where hopefully we're gonna get
composable algorithms thanks this is one
more thing I'll say this is my first
time giving a talk so more probably than
others I would love feedback so here's
the link you can go to and yeah
questions what row for the example of
the RMS can we in 10 seconds implement a
better version that is more accurate for
doubles functionally sorry so for the
RMS example yes what implement a more
accurate version of it with your style
do you imagine how to I mean the typical
way is to find the maximum first the
maximum element in absolute value and
scale all the elements through that as
you sum the squares yeah my guess is
there probably is or serve and do you
wanna respond yeah I'm wondering if you
would do that you throw the throw - Mike
- you can use a balanced reduction out
whether the sound likely doesn't provide
any but it's well known in literature to
provide more stable and and know that
less loss of precision so balanced
production less loss of precision for
the RMS example that was in mad gobbled
slides other questions
No all right thanks guys
[Applause]